yeah welcome to the CVM plane what's the
name Hardy mill don't think i have a
play before from the UK about 2330 2300
rated here i got a request to learn to
read out them to rita the record the
rating of the opponents because some
some um I'm spectators they use it use
the mobile phone for watching the videos
and it seems to be that you cannot
really read the rating on that on the
mobile phones okay so castles what
differ Thank d 5s is right here but all
this set looks looks a bit shaky
hmm i don't know this is a bit weird
with a four and c3 or is it cancels i
don't know castles he might play deform
okay let's let's let's go go ahead him
play yeah but the end he is playing not
too challenging d3 maybe this is the
best move i'm not saying it is is bad
but then this was not what I was worried
about okay so how to continue here night
the g3 possibly coming on night III even
hmm okay maybe it's some time to to use
the C porn
I'm sorry so night 2 g-3 airy don't know
how to continue a media form d5 deform
gain space but it makes the beasts
having Bishop look a bit stupid I try to
play c4 c5 see for activating the pieces
and making sure that the bishop on b7
actually does something but I want to
get out of the default first this is why
Quincy 7 was was played c4 immediately I
don't think was advisable with the rook
on d1 opposing the Queen so get get it's
also protecting e5 so that if he takes
d5 I can just recaptured Avenue 5
protected two times well this looks like
it should be an ok position yeah so it's
basically ignoring what i'm doing right
yeah this happens quite frequently ok
let's play c4
yeah I'm saying that he's ignoring what
I'm doing because the night on g3
doesn't protect you for any more so it's
a it's an active looking move but it's
not so clear what this night is really
doing if you take see for now I can take
e 4 and this is a bit a bit of a problem
now for him as if he takes d5 I take d
33 and then have a for the e5 efore with
a big Fork so it's not clear what he's
supposed to do now I'm also threatening
to take d3 and d4 so it's really am a
bit awkward now maybe you can somehow
make it takes d5 work each XD 5c takes
d3 capture and on e4 play d 6 or
something but yeah this is some what I
actually expected not much else to do ok
so what now probably end let's take here
it has to check with the bishop and then
I have at least night be three with a
good with a good game yeah let's do that
and in fact after the rook moves night
c5 is strong after eight X be 5 I take d
three teky Freud win-win material so
let's see five is strong I'm threatening
to just take on e4 now and take on d3
antigone for so I don't see a good reply
he basically has lost two moves with
night f5 which was really a mistimed
ya know I can take you for I'm only
wondering on how I should take it take
with the pawn or with with the one of
the nights
taking with the pawn yeah taken with the
poem probably it gains a temple on this
night and I can also take a for now but
them now should I take a phone probably
probably yes
some two pawns up now okay he's got
chances to to get something back but
tell me yeah this this is probably
you're not really threatening much
Bishop f8 is a good defender there now I
have 93 as a possible
yeah it's just two points really
yeah the doubletree so it's not like a
completely healthy two extra parts but
nice and yeah he doesn't really have a
good move yes this one the question is
some should i move the night or just
allow him to take c5 it would give me
two bishops you will get 1 pound bag but
then it's still it's two bishops hmm now
not easy night d3 is also nice maybe
maybe this one maybe a three at night d
three mmm that's what a taxi 3 and a 3
okay but we should be six at the end
okay son not not that one okay just just
keep it simple I keep keep a form
protected intending a possible Bishop b5
which would provoke c4 very undesirable
move it just asks why what are you going
to do now you can take c5 and take on e4
with this this just Nets me two bishops
um when possible a possible rooker
property three i roped into I wonder I
wonder if i take here I have to King
takes root d tubes of funny planning
motif and lighted and Queen checks i
just take you for this is quite funny
I'm done 22 seconds um this is important
no this time whining this was the idea
yeah let's get rid of the Queen's
he's not very very quick fortunately
check
check check check white forfeits on time
yes this was pretty straightforward game
after he played night f5 which I think
was was really a mistype move here this
95 I think he needs to take care of of
the center I'm not quite sure with the
with them what move exactly it's only
clear that this will lead to some
trouble I think how the computer
actually wants to play d4 interesting
this is so interesting i'm not sure if
it is good but deform the ideas of two
takes to play here and if i take you for
let's be five hey yeah don't really
trust that for what but maybe maybe this
is an option after the rear feet yup
like it sir it's very clearly better
yeah playing all the combos this is
quite spooky sometimes if you really
managed to to hit the hit the red ones
okay this isn't a car move but it's not
bad yeah I think it was a pretty pretty
straightforward game I mean here this
Bishop f2 was was a funny funny mutti
King takes root T to check this was cute
so it's just another point very computer
issue but once in a while you see those
things alright thanks for watching